[Music]
submit
your reckless actions endanger the world
[Music]
[Music]
mimi
is that you
you cannot run forever leave
immediately
[Applause]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
fear is the little death that brings
total obliteration
i will face my fear
i will permit it to pass over and
through me
and when it has gone past
i will turn the inner eye to see its
path
for the fear is gone
there will be nothing
only i
will remain
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the more we know about salazar slytherin
and the dark arts the better prepared
we'll be
if either of you uses dark magic i will
notify the headmaster immediately
unforgivable curses are so named
for a reason
a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable the dark
hearts seem harmless until it's too late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
what do we do now it's up to us i can
teach you crucio
or i can cast it on me
i'm ready
you've made your choice
what have the two of you done
[Music]
stand the [ __ ] back it's hammer time
this way for the happy ending jimmy
[Music]
humanity's survival depends on the red
gold pumping through my veins well
sounds like you're the star of the show
now this [ __ ]
i will not have this bevel in my house
[Music]
gosh this is beyond insane
ah
[Music]
uh
now
left
uh
pressure check
releasing the power
no no no no
wow
so
jim gordon never gave up on anything
that's why gotham city is still here
it's why i'm still here
[Music]
and i've known for a while now that
someday like him
i'd have to work with you
i've seen plenty of criminals in my
career but
nothing could have prepared me for this
[Music]
well well if it isn't
brat girl
gotham city is at her weakest
there's blood in the water
and the sharks are circling
they're all making their moves
play nice
but we aren't going to give up
a storm has risen over gotham
nothing can stop it
see you later for me
i need your help
your skills
your knowledge
your adaptability
you got my back
this biopic is based on a true story
my story
soon
the world will feel the cold as i do
i got one last little surprise for you
i'm just here to kick your ass
pre-order now
[Music]
hello friends it's your old pal stan
coming to you through the magic of
marketing to let you know that your
search for quality entertainment is
about to bear fruit but i wouldn't be
doing my job if i just drop the details
on you without a little build up i want
you to see the kind of fine dining
establishments you'll be visiting like
this one get lost
and if escapism is your cup of flavor
you can't do much better than this
exotic and extremely remote island stay
back
how did you find me
return to monkey island launches
september 19th which happens to be
international talk like a pirate day but
you don't have to wait you can order it
right now before it's even out something
we in the marketing industry call a
pre-order as a bonus i'm ready to unload
this shipment of beautiful horse armor
to anyone who pre-orders return to
monkey island it'll look fantastic in
your inventory wait you missed a spot
i've got to go now i've got a lot of
irons and a lot of fires you know how it
is but i'll be back to steal every scene
i'm in and return to monkey island i'll
see you
there all preorder customers will
receive the exclusive horse armor item
in their inventory please note that the
horse armor has no practical use in game
and in no way will contribute to the
gameplay puzzles or narrative of return
to monkey island
[Music]
the sand has memories
[Music]
memories of our past
when gods walked this world
and our heroes stood amongst them
but the gods vanity grew
and in their struggle
we were cast away
only remnants of these stories remain
in the sand
in the ruins of this shattered broken
world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
even in ruins we endure
we won't let
go now we can stand for ourselves
and face
gods
come back to the city and join the
deadliest spectacle of this season
i'm going to tell you a story
about a species that survived millennia
homony and atalensis
homorodiciensis
homo erectus all of them wiped out by
the deadliest species of all
us i am astrid
this is the new arena
and my advice for you
stay alive
every day you fight for survival but
today you fight for glory
anyone can be a warrior what makes you
different is the spirit of a champion
most stories in the borderlands
start bloody
they end bloody too
sometimes
all it takes to change the galaxy
is a trio of losers trying to get
through a bad day
we are in the middle of a tdr invasion
leave immediately this area is
they think there was a vault key being
kept on the station if we can find
whatever's in that vault before td or
does we can change our lives
they're bad at this like really bad
tedious has many guns
talking guns guns with legs i'm gonna
blast you so freaking fat
[Applause]
[Applause]
i always wanted to change the universe
for the better and now we actually can
but more importantly we'll be drowning
in
why are you people like this
if you happen to see any corpses along
the way uh don't worry about them
they're just uh
yeah don't worry about them
[Music]
[Music]
well we're actually hitting here
holy crap that was cool
jesus it's so gross you even went in
there
yeah so stop diving into it
[ __ ] she's filling the place with sludge
stay in the air
you better not fall in
hey i'm still here you can still use me
if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect attacks
i'll slice them yeah i'll cut their
heads off
and i'll rip their limbs off do
everything long and cut right into them
i'll cut that
[ __ ] off and eat it you know this
sludge matches your toxic personality
that wasn't even a good one
surprise flesh
hey it's
[Music]
just for you
bet you're just as nice and squishy on
the inside as the rest of them let me
out of bounty hunter
wow we're having our first real boss
fight together
my soldiers are extremely strong
honestly i don't think they were we're
new at this and it was pretty easy to
kill them all if i'm going out i'm
taking you with me
[ __ ] just stay alive i think she's
basically done for
good
[Music]
it was a simple perimeter scan
escorting resources
but we were ambushed by colon raiders
[Music]
one wing used cover to keep himself safe
on approach
[Music]
while another group found a tunnel in
the structure to sneak behind them
let's do this
it worked but just before a carrier
battle group arrived
we scrambled bombers
perfect for attacking capital ships
we protected the resourcers while they
hauled in the goods
which meant we could roll out assault
frigates
the raiders weren't pushovers but
command countered their hit and run
tactics
the way their carrier exploded
beautiful
and we even grabbed a little souvenir
that missile frigate
is ours now
[Music]
can you hear me
i hope this reaches you
this city is falling
apart chaos
madness
death
and there might be no going back
[Music]
but you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lie
i might be asking too much of you
but i don't have a choice
only you can do this
please
help me
finally
we meet
son
[Music]
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right buddy i'm here for you don't
worry
don't give up
protect
fulfill
[Music]
your destiny
so
[Music]
hop in the box liar
in the crux of reality
there exists two lies
one before
the shadow
and one
behind the eye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dark tide is a first person co-op game
set in the grim dark future of warhammer
40 000.
welcome to tertium a sprawling hive city
on the brink of destruction
you are a reject a convict free to serve
the inquisition in this darkest of hours
it is your duty to fight
and
if necessary
die
for the emperor
can expect no help
no reinforcements
you
are tersham's last line of defense
[Music]
the battle for tourism is about to begin
rejects will rise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you